think if I identified as a dog and my
mother took that seriously that would be
kind and nice and a good thing well I
what I think would be kind and nice and
a good thing and speaking as a mother is
exactly what you said it's about
embracing our children embracing their
use of imagination and supporting them
through I mean your fortive years what
about with the dogs like like should
should they support this and give me a
collar like I'm just genuinely asking
question that is a ridiculous example
we're not we're not talking about cats
and dogs here we're talking about gender
but then I would be pretending to be a
guy which is something that I'm not